I've gotten feedback that all the Chuck
Norris imagery in the last video might
have been a little bit too overwhelming
so for this video I've included
something a little bit more soothing so
let's try to simplify some more
expressions and we'll see we're just
applying ideas that we already knew
about so let's say I want to simplify
the expression 2 times 3x plus 5
well this literally means to 3x plus 5
so this is the exact same thing as so
this is 1 3x plus 5 and then to that I'm
gonna add another 3x plus 5 this is
literally what 2 times 3x plus 5 means
well this Liz the same thing as I mean
if we just look at it right over here we
have now 2 3 X's so we can write it as 2
times 3x plus we have two 5s plus we
have 2 5 so plus 2 times 5 but you might
say hey Sal isn't this just the
distributive property that I know from
arithmetic I've essentially just
distributed the to 2 times 3 X 2 times
3x plus 2 times 5 and I would tell you
yes it is and I'm the whole reason why
I'm doing this is just to show you that
it is exactly what you already know but
with that out of the way let's continue
to simplify it so when you multiply the
2 times the 3x the 2 times the 3x you
get 6x you multiply the 2 times the 5
you get 10 so this simplified to 6x plus
10 now let's try something that's a
little bit more involved once again
really just things that you already know
so let's say I had let's say that I had
7 times let's say 3y minus 5 minus 2
times 10 10 plus let's say plus 10 plus
4y let's see if we can simplify this
well let's work on the left hand side of
the expression the 7 times 3y minus 5 we
just have to distribute the 7 so this is
going to be 7 times 3y which is going to
give us 21 Y or if I had three wise
seven times it's going to be 21 wise
you want to think about it and then I
have seven times we're gonna be careful
with the sign this is seven times
negative five seven times negative five
is negative 35 so we've simplified this
part of it let's simplify the right-hand
side so you might be tempted to say oh 2
times 10 and 2 times 4y and then
subtract them and if you do that right
and you distribute the subtraction it
would work out but I like to think of
this as negative 2 as negative 2 and
we're gonna distribute the negative 2
times 10 and then we're going to
distribute the negative or times 10 and
the negative 2 times 4y so negative 2
times 10 negative 2 times the 10 is
negative 20 so it's Nate minus 20 right
over here and then negative 2 times 4y
negative 2 times 4 is negative 8 so it's
going to be negative 8y so it's quite a
minus 8y right over here and are we done
simplifying well no there's a little bit
more that we can do we can't add the 21
Y to the negative 35 or the negative 20
because these are adding different
things or subtracting different things
but we do have two things that are
multiplying Y we have the let me do them
all in this green color you have 21 Y's
right over here and then from that we
are subtracting we are what we can view
it as from that we are subtracting eight
Y's so 21 of something might if I have
21 of something and I take eight of them
away I'm left with 13 of that something
so those are going to simplify to 13 Y's
and then I have negative 35 is in a new
color and then I have negative 35 minus
20 and so that's just going to simplify
to negative 55 negative 55 so this whole
thing simplified using a little bit of
the distributive property and combining
similar or like terms we got to 13 y
minus 55